hi whoa maybe there's a little
enthusiastic there hi hi it's it's
better this is better how are ya
wow that was actually pretty awesome for
like one session removed before the end
of the conference you know we're in the
homestretch we get a little tired but
that's good that's good see lots of
bright eyes out there this is awesome
well you've come to a great talk at
least I think so my name is Spencer
Shannon Bach and I'm here to talk to you
today about expression trees in c-sharp
now C sharps just the language example
but you could do this just about it you
can do this in vb.net as well most of
this stuff applies I mean vb.net people
out there that want to admit it yeah
yeah there's a few of your this time
still em once occasionally so first
things first got to get this out of the
way you can find me on Twitter at
Schneider box just my last name so get
that peace babe you don't have to write
it down right you can get the slides
plus more at Schneids net i will also be
tweeting out a link to the slides and
the link to a few other resources and a
few other things along the way so I'm
gonna be using Twitter throughout the
presentation to tweet out some example
things that I think are useful some
little demos that you could use and
follow along with as I'm giving them
alright so without further ado let's
start by talking about expression trees
now how many people how many people in
this room have used something like this
a link expression either the query
syntax or the lambda syntax to query a
database how many people query a
database entity framework linked to
sequel
all right all that good stuff all right
all right very good how many people have
been asked to render a field like this
using asp.net they're using asp.net MVC
and they're like II D at HTML editor for
and then it just produces a bunch of
magic stuff and like validator for and
all that all right very good how many of
you have been asked to ever use some
kind of code where you had to select one
or more members of class a property of
some kind kind of like this right all
right well if you have done anything
like write a lambda expression that
you've used expression trees even if you
had no idea and so we're gonna talk
about that we're gonna
talk about some examples in the real
world in libraries that you use every
day where you may not even be aware of
them and as and a real-world example
that I've used as long as as well as a
few that you can use that kind of chew
on to see how expression trees could
help you in your development life so
let's start by talking about what
expression trees are and before we can
talk about expression trees I think it's
valuable I think it's useful to talk
about what a lambda expressions so this
is a lambda expression this is one
that's declare it inline inside of a
variable so we have func of string
string which just says defines a
function signature that has a it's a
function that takes in a string and
returns a string and our two upper
function it all it's going to do is take
in that string and call its two upper
function on that and so what happens
when I call that function right in line
because you can do that if you've never
done this before it's cool you can do
that so what would I reasonably expect
to get as a result of this function
I'd probably expect to get my name
capitalized spencer's go from lowercase
to uppercase all right
pretty straightforward let's declare the
exact same thing exactly the same way
except we're going to add an expression
so this is a expression of func of
string string and we're gonna do that it
looks the same so that top line works so
we're gonna try on the bottom line what
do you think I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
a compile time error well what the heck
is up with that I mean they're they look
almost exactly the same they look it
looks like lambda function both of those
things reply those both of those things
are compiled above code so what's going
on so the key difference between a
lambda and an expression is that a
lambda does the thing an expression tree
an expression a lambda expression
specifically describes the lambda that
does the thing so this is really
important though because this is this
makes this is actually a really
important feature of expressions as they
relate to c-sharp and vb.net these
things it's really cool they have they
share a property called homo iconicity
and i think i'm saying that right i
don't know i've never looked it up when
home like Anisa t basically says that
the
syntax that you can use to write a
function you can use that exact same
syntax to declare expressions that
describe that function so it's a really
powerful concept because it looks
natural it looks and feels natural when
we write entity framework queries or
we're selecting members using HTML
editor for anything like that it feels
like a natural part of the language
because it is it feels like you're just
naturally just writing a lambda function
even if they are doing some cool magic
we're gonna talk about what that magic
is we're gonna talk about what we can do
with expressions so we can read them
create them and use them so let's take
our two upper example here we're gonna
go ahead and decompose this thing we're
gonna break him down into his component
parts so as you know a lambda is made up
of a set of parameters zero or more and
a body which tells you what the thing
does right so in this case our string
takes this our string function takes in
a string returns a string okay and a
parameter and an expression can be
broken down and read by its component
pieces for example I can take the the
representation of this thing during
runtime and I can say and I can start
interrogating that expression and say
what are you what what is it that you do
and we're gonna get some code
representations of that expression so on
the left side we've got our parameters
so what we're gonna get is what's called
a parameter expression and a parameter
expression simply defines a parameter to
an expression right and then on the
other side on the right side week we can
break this down into two different
things so we have a method call
expression which calls string two uppers
basically representing that call to
string two upper and then we have the
parameter expression that says this is
the target this was the thing that I
called two upper on so you can break
this down you can inspect that
expression at runtime and ask it things
about what it does which is really cool
and we'll show you why in a bit
you can also create them so this is an
example of creating that just the same
as we did before and we do this a lot
when we use entity framework or we use
auto map or libraries like that so this
is good this is useful but it's mostly
for useful for libraries that consume
the expressions well what if I told you
you could create them at runtime
and you can using what's called the
expression API which is really neat you
can use the expression API to build
expressions at runtime very easily and
let me show you
so again functions having parameters in
a body here's an example of one that
also takes in a stretchy it takes in an
object that has a last name property
hello comma with the last name so again
talking about that parameter expression
this is how you declare instead of you
know if we declared something like this
inline where that X we get a we get a
expression that is a parameter that is
an expression it contains parameters and
contains a body but we can also call we
can also build them at runtime using the
expression API and we do that by using
these static methods on the expression
class so we call expression dot
parameter and what we do is we have one
of two signatures we have a signature so
one thing about a parameter it always
has a type right it could be object it
could be string but it always has a type
so we can declare a parameter inline
that has a type of string right and then
we could also give it a name right so if
we didn't do anything that top line its
parameter name would be automatically as
we attached it to an expression it would
just be R 1 or R 0 or whatever it would
be
the bottom one allows you to also name
that expression because a parameter can
also have a name right constant
expression is another expression there's
another example of an expression that
represents a constant some kind of
string or a number something then inline
in code that can be read and it is
basically just a wrapper and says this
expression just points to something that
already exists inside of code outside of
the expression world and a method call
expression is a call to a method right
so this is how you would declare one
that now one thing about the expression
API is that it is very there's a lot to
it right there's a lot to there's lots
of different kinds of calls right
there's calls to static methods there's
calls to instance methods so there's
lots of different ways to construct a
parameter for or construct a expression
for declaring a function but here's a
simple example so we're just going to
use just a little bit of reflection
we're going to declare a parameter that
is a that is of type string and then we
are going to get a reference to the two
up
method inside of the string class so
we've broken down into one of two things
if you never used get method method we
get the name of the method and then we
get the things the the empty the this is
an array this type dot empty x is an
empty array of types it just basically
says what is the signature of this
function that's the one we want to find
and then we can use the expression call
to actually declare our method calling
in line so we're gonna build this thing
we're gonna build this guy right here
we're gonna do our string string to
upper and we're gonna do it using the
expression API let me show you so string
to upper starts with our expression
parameter so we've got type of string
but we also want to give it a name we've
called them STR so we're just gonna give
we're gonna call him STR and we're gonna
declare that expression dot parameter
we're gonna go ahead and call them STRs
we're gonna use the second argument of
that expression parameter function and
then of course we want the reference to
two uppers so we're gonna do exactly
what we did before get a reference to
two upper the two upper method call and
then we're going to construct the body
of our expressions we got the parameter
we've got the thing that's going to be
inside the body now we're gonna actually
call our parameter R Express that or
construct the thing that calls that so
we're gonna call expression comm we're
gonna pass in firstly the parameter
because we're calling it the two upper
method on our parameter right we're
calling string str2 upper so that's the
target so that's what we're gonna do and
we're going to give a reference to our
to upper method and then we're gonna do
this this is expression dot lambda
expression dot lambda what it will do is
will actually convert this into a
function that can be called inline so
here's how you would actually invoke it
so we've got our expression dot lambda
here we give it a body and we give it a
parameter if there's zero or more right
so we've cut we've now exactly created
what's called a lambda expression and
what we can do in line with this is we
can either read it or we can use it we
can compile this compile method which
will lit and it will literally when you
call lambda dot compile it will build
that in memory and it will make it into
an actual function and then we can call
dynamic invoke on it pass in the
arguments right because we know that
it's of a it is a function that takes in
a string so we're going to call it with
spencer and then what we're gonna end up
with is we're gonna get the capital isin
it we're gonna get my name capitalized
right so one thing about this is it's
not strongly typed you actually press it
in an array of parameters but if you
happen to know at runtime the type of
the function if you know the signature
of the function you can call expression
dot lambda and what it'll give you is a
lambda expression that actually is fully
typed so that way when you call dot
compile and then you call invoke you get
strong you it will be strongly typed so
that way you can't pass in you know a
number or zero arguments or three
arguments like you could if you call
dynamic invoke alright so pretty useful
so far so that's our that's our thing
what could we do with expressions we can
read them we can use them we can create
them so let's talk about some of the
real-world use cases for expressions the
ones that we we use everyday maybe take
it for granted we don't even know what's
going on under the hood so let's let's
peel back those layers let's look under
the rock so got env framework which I
saw a lot of hands for a 2d frame which
is awesome how many people use Auto
mapper Auto mapper is one of my favorite
time-saving libraries if you were in my
workshop I talked about Auto mapper like
I had the same way I talked about any
framework I love them I love them to
death
so we're gonna go through how both of
those use expressions to do their job so
entity framework is a is a piece of
functionality that oh is a wrapper over
a database right and it allows us one of
the things that allows us to do which
has a lot of power is write link
expressions which entity framework will
automatically translate into sequel
which is really useful right it saves us
a lot of time we don't have to write a
lot of nasty sequel which is great so
something like this where if we had a
roof we had a products table and the
products table had a name and a price we
could say products if we wanted to go
through and find all the products and
then we wanted to find the most
expensive eggs in a list so we we could
call DB dot products called dot ware
which gives us which gives us a what's
called a predicate we can pass in we
pass in that product and then we just
give it some kind of we return bool and
say well PM equals eggs we've done this
before right if not entity framework
linked to objects certainly and then we
and then we call order by descending so
the cool thing about in a framework is
it will take
that knowledge and it will translate it
into sequel which is really cool right
so we get select star for products where
name equals eggs order by price
descending roughly how many people have
really looked at the sequel that entity
framework how many people like looking
at the sequel having to be framer
commits nobody so this is like a very
cleaned up example it gives you gives
you a right idea of course entity
framework behaves a little differently
it omits consoles lots of crazy sequel
but there's some magic in the middle
there's something in the middle that's
happening that's causing entity
framework to take that expression and
then turn it into a sequel query is it
magic
probably must be right I mean if you if
all you're doing is writing queries you
don't know what's going on to the hood
which is which is fine it's just doing
its magic right so interesting property
about DVD products it is what's called
an iqueryable it is an it is of type
iqueryable which is like ienumerable
with a few extra things right i
queryable is the magic that enables
things like expressions and lay it
enables us to look at expressions that
we pass in at any framework and do stuff
with them so here's an example of a
numeral is so queryable in innumerable
very similar and they both have lambda
expressions or sorry they both use link
right they both have where and select
you may have not even ever noticed this
right so if you've got innumerable if
you've got a numerable and you call dot
where you've got an innumerable you call
dot where you get that extension method
right where is an extension method that
takes in a funk that says of passing
your thing of type t and then return a
bool and then what it'll do is typically
it'll use that to filter down some
results but queryable is a little
different queryable doesn't take in
functions it takes in expressions that
describe functions so what does that
mean that means that this one can be
interpreted at runtime by entity
framework which is really awesome so
this a this is our little this is our
little query that we need or our little
link query that we need to decompose
down into its component parts and turn
it into sequel and how does it do that
how does that do how does it make that
magic happen it does that by
implementing something called an
expression visitor which is used to read
and operate and sometimes
modify expressions so let me show you
let's break this down one piece at a
time
so we've got our DB products we know
that represents our products table so
now we're trying to query that table so
what we're gonna do is what's gonna
happen is that the expression visitor
that expressions gonna go into the
expression visitor it's gonna be red
it's gonna be red it's gonna be red and
then it's going to be translated right
so one of the things that it can do that
it's really useful for is visiting
expressions just reading them so that
you can translate them into another
language in this case we're trying to
translate c-sharp into sequel and it
does a good job of that so when we pass
in P name equals eggs
it becomes we're name equals eggs it
becomes something that sequel can
interpret it becomes the sequel language
this is what's called a binary
expression and a binary expression is
really important because it represents
something that has a left side a right
side and an operator in the middle
greater than greater than or equal to
equals not equals that kind of thing so
a binary expression has a left side a
right side and an operator a node type
right the node type is usually like
equal not equal that kind of thing
so the expression visitor reads each
piece of that expression and operates on
that expression so when we look at this
P dot name equals eggs we're looking
down and were breaking down that where
clause we know that the left side P dot
name roughly translates to probably
translates to a name column in sequel
we know that the double equals is also
something that can be read from the
binary expression and we know that a
double equals is a single equals in in
sequel or at least the event the
expression visitor does and then of
course the single the the eggs string
the egg constant gets passed in as a
constant to this function right to the
where clot to our call to where and of
course we don't have double quoted
strings inside a sequel so it just
translates it to a single quote strings
so what it will make it into sequel so
that way it can be executed against the
sequel database let it do the thing that
it wants to do so now we know the magic
in the middle is actually an expression
visitor and we could spend all day we
could do an entire workshop on how to
implement an expression visitor we're
not going to cover that today we're just
going to cover what it is because it's
important to understand kind of
what's going on under the hood the
expressions are being read so that way
then we can do something with them right
so of course one thing about c-sharp and
sequel is that c-sharp is decidedly not
sequel it took me a while to find an
example a good example of a sequel query
this is an example of a sequel query
that entity framework would admit entity
framework has to work really hard in
order to translate what is essentially
c-sharp into sequel right because
they're not the same language they don't
have they have a lot of similar
properties but not everything we can't
write c-sharp and expect it to operate
like sequel I had a developer one time
asked me he said uh well I wrote the
sequel query and and and I put two
things in the where clause and I just
figured it I just figured that the and
the and part if I had two things in the
where clause if the first and wasn't
satisfied that it would just
short-circuit and look not look at the
other one and it will gain performance
that way that is not how that works
those kinds of idiosyncrasies make a
train things like that make translating
c-sharp - sequel difficult right another
great example is what's that case
sensitivity inside of the collation
inside of a sequel server database if
you have an in-memory sequel server
database or so you see a database that
entity framework is using for testing or
something and you do we're equals it's
gonna be case sensitive
but a lot of times how many people have
a sequel server instance that is not
case-sensitive by default it's awesome
right but those kind of videos sync
receives exists we have to correct for
them we could all read this if we really
wanted to nobody wants to read this but
you see that this is the kind of being
that this is like output of a really you
know big arguably nasty linq query
entity framework has to work hard right
that's part of the expression visitors
job another thing that expression
visitor can do is modify expressions
kind of because expression the
expression API returns immutable objects
which is great because they will always
have a state and when you get them back
as long as the code as long as that line
of code executes and you don't get an
exception you know it's a valid
expression which is really cool so
expression visitor can be used to modify
and let's look at an example of this so
let's say that every time
we had an expression that we wanted to
look at we could construct a visitor to
always make sure that when we're looking
at that if there's a string that's
passed in that we translate that
expression to a to upper expression so
now we're using this now we're replacing
it we're still keeping that we're still
keeping that variable right but we're
also now calling to upper on it so
instead of a constant program it's
constant expression for example we'll
end up with a method call expression and
we could do that by implementing an
expression visitor and calling busy and
implementing the visit method so
basically if a spray if the node type
equals to expression type type parameter
we want to make sure to return it we
don't want to mess with parameters right
but if it's anything else it's fair game
to be called to be modified so if the
node type because there's a property on
node on all I called type on all
expressions if the node type equals type
of string then we're gonna use instead
of returning the expression we're
actually going to modify it we're
actually going to replace it with the
method call expression and call to up or
on it such that when we do this we
declare a function in line called
spencey string apparently and we take in
an S which is a string and then return s
belongs to Spencer if we run that
through the two upper visitor what will
happen is is that expression that we get
after we call visit and convert will be
a new expression and when we compile it
and invoke it we'll get the cheese
belongs to Spencer and everything will
be capitalized so I have a demo for you
and I am going to if you've got a
computer and you want to follow along
I'm going to oh boy does this Twitter
link still work oh right I'm going to go
here oh boy this is gonna be there we go
all right so I'm gonna tweet out the
link to this so this is a thing called
ODOT net fiddle which is really useful
for sharing really small snippets of
code so in DC Minnesota tweet that out
now you got a link to this dotnet fiddle
in case you want to follow along and in
case you want to reference it later
you've always got a link in to the
slides too and well cats out of the bag
because it's already run and it's
already it's already been run before
but you'd get to see you you can take
this and then you can experiment with it
right so it's got our two uh per visitor
declared with our visit type and you can
take this and mess with it it's a little
bit of example code it makes it makes
messing with expressions a little easier
sometimes when you have a little
expression so if we wanted to call to
lower instead we won't rename it to
upper visitors now the to lower visitor
we've added a bug right I'm gonna run
this and you're gonna see when we go
through when the expression is modified
and looked at it's going to return
that's maybe a little bit too small it's
gonna return the cheese belongs to
Spencer in lower case right so just an
example if you have an expression you
can take them and modify them using a
visitor let's see all right talk about
auto map Auto mapper is one of my
favorite libraries it saves me from
writing glue code and glue code means
that I'm doing fun stuff as opposed to
boring stuff instead of you know
declaring another another clad another
instance of a class that has all the
properties of the previous one I can use
Auto mapper to copy those properties
over to that class it's awesome right
and you can manage your maps and use
them to do some specific things
including things like interact with link
let me show you so let's this is an
example of a map right so create map if
you call create map on an object on a
class on two classes what you'll get is
it will create that map in memory and it
will manage it in memory it will hold it
in memory and when you call dot map from
this mapper it will done go look in that
map and use it so what will you like
property so if it's a string first name
it on one class and a string first name
on another when you call map it will
automatically copy those things over if
you need to do some custom stuff you can
call for member and say for the target
property first name I want you to map
from my first name so you can give
autumn after a little bit more
information to do its job really well so
those are so these things these things
that we're calling those lambdas those
are actually expressions right because
those things are not actually being
function are not functions that are
being called they're just being
interpreted and there
being interpreted for our convey and
they're being interpreted and what we
get is a nice experience when we're
developing it's very convenient one of
the hardest things that I think that I
explain to junior developers is when
that where clause that we're in like DV
products that where clause has actually
never invoked
it's just read and translated right same
thing here same thing for auto-mapping
talk about project two if you were in my
workshop I talked about project two a
lot because it's one of my godly things
I love this thing because it can use
expressions in really powerful ways let
me show you so let's say that you have
some kind of item detail class and for
our sake we'll just say it has an ID and
a name and a hundred other property so
102 properties to map right so and then
we've got it we need to project it to a
list of some kind right so we just need
to take that and we just need to copy
over the ID and the name from the
database and then put it in a list if
we're you know trying to select it in a
in a drop-down selection or you know on
a web page or something right so we can
combine Auto mapper and edit the
framework and call map
ID'd item detail model give it the type
item detail model it'll say oh you're
giving me a set of item details I know
that I'm going to translate them into an
item detail model and return the right
data but here be dragons when the
dragons come in because this will call
select star on that table and how did
you how did the DBAs that you work with
love select star they hate it right you
don't want to make them DBAs mad because
then then they yell at you and then they
make you refactor your code right so
project two is a really powerful thing
that can help come to the rescue and
kind of take some of that pain away so
instead of calling mapper da item detail
model you know array of the item detail
model to return this what we could do
instead is call project two so DB item
details dot project two there's actually
an argument that gets passed in it's the
from your mapper instance object you
actually pass in its could the mappers
configuration but you get the idea if
you're using the static auto map or how
many people are using the static API for
auto mapper okay Wow very good very few
of you if you've got existing code you
know don't you know you don't always
need to refactor it but if you do
use the instance base there's an
additional argument that's important
well what this will do what's really
cool is that Auto mapper will use
expressions under the hood and tell
entity framework they're really only
selecting these two properties so when
you call project two on this on this
item details model and tell it to
project it to the item detail model
right you'll get a select ID common name
so Auto mapper and entity framework can
work together a little bit to actually
take those expressions and use them to
write more performant code or if
performance is in the issue and you know
use it to write code that your DBA won't
hate so let me talk about a real-world
example at my company Mac when we
backwards so I work for a start-up
called rivet and rivet makes integration
data there may make they make
integration software so they're making
data and workflows there they're trying
to connect to systems to might either
connect lists data for accounting
systems like customers and vendors or
emulate workflows for integration of
certain products really powerful really
cool stuff and it's a startup I've been
there for about four years and we
encountered a problem in an early
version of the platform so we
essentially what we did was we Dahl ways
pull in a local cache of all of the data
so that way we can manipulate it and
reference it very easily there's a lot
of good reasons to do that so what we do
is we would create those in sequel we'd
create sequel tables for all those and
then we'd copy in the data pretty
straightforward the thing we needed to
do was be able to map one entity to
another and they used stored procs
because by the time I got there they
started using stored proxy for
performance what they were doing
previously was easing entity framework
calling for each of the objects on the
objects and then copying over the data
it was very slow it was not performant
enough and stored procedures because
they're compiled and because their
sequel and use insert set based logic
they were a lot faster so let's take
this for example
we're gonna take a Salesforce customer
and make it into a quickbooks customer
so oftentimes when you're working with
data from different systems as you know
you've done integration before at least
at least a couple of times i'm sure
it's a lot of our jobs these days and of
course we know that sometimes the data
doesn't always quite match up if it's
not a property name maybe it's just kind
of a purpose right it's maybe the
property doesn't quite represent the
property on the other thing right but
for let's take for example that we have
like a Salesforce customer and a
QuickBooks customer and we want a the
Salesforce customer for one reason or
another is called customer name and we
wanted to map it to the QuickBooks name
property on that customer and then we
have a create date which kind of sort of
goes with open date will we go with it
that's just what our product definition
says so we go with it so our job is to
copy over all of these properties from
one entity to another so this is what
our stored procs looks like we'd say
insert QuickBooks customer name open
date select customer name create date
from Salesforce customers and of course
there was a little more complication to
that we wanted to make sure we weren't
including duplicate data for example but
you get the general ideas that we would
write stored procs to move this data
around now do that for hundreds of
objects and thousands of properties oh
and by the way don't ever make a mistake
how many people love writing sequel
because it's just it just helps you out
so much from keeping you from making
mistakes right right
people the people that raised their
hands those are you know sadists those
are the kinds of love pain right but for
all it for me I this was not a scalable
solution for our company this wasn't
scalable we were making mistakes all the
time because sequel doesn't provide a
lot of those protections that were just
used to in c-sharp so we had some
problems there so I went to my boss one
day and I barely knew I knew of
expressions I knew about them
conceptually I don't know if I watched a
talk write a blog post whatever I knew
what they could do I knew that they
could be read and interpreted so I went
to my boss and I said Michael I think
there's a different way I think there's
a better way we can do this these stored
procedures there's a lot of pain
associated with them but I think that we
can do this in code by defining maps and
code and he said you can show me a proof
of concept you have an hour so I said
all right I've got an hour so in 40
minutes I had some working mock workable
example and it essentially kind of
looked like this and what this did was
we were able to define classes kind of
like Maps like kind of like Auto mapper
does we were able to define a class that
would represent a mapping between those
two objects
so we would say source filled from the
customer from the Salesforce customer is
equal to the QVC name rim so what we
actually did actually think I have that
inverted a little bit if we I think that
the trim belongs on the customer name so
we wanted to trim the customer name
first because a lot of the older systems
that we integrate with they just love
padding spaces on the ends of things
they just love doing it or at the
beginning right I don't know why they do
but they do sure I'll deal with that but
in QuickBooks they don't like doing that
so we wanted to trim that name and then
we wanted to say well the source field
createdate we really want to take it and
put it to the open date or and but we
don't always have a value but it's a
required value at another system so
we'll do date time dot now in case that
value is null so the thing that I had to
do was write an expression visitor
because I had to I had to preserve the
performance of the stored procedure
while making it really convenient for
developers to write so I had to write an
expression visitor and then I had to
handle pretty much any type of
expression that we wanted to translate
how many people have ever tried to call
a method or something inside of
annotated framework query and any
frameworks like I can't translate that I
don't know what to do it throws an
exception right a lot of us encountered
that error we had to do the same thing
because sometimes the functionality just
didn't copy over right so when we called
trim on a name property what we were
actually wanting to do was call L trim
our trim inside of sequel right and then
when we use the coalesce operator we
wanted to actually use the is null Appa
we when it actually translate to the is
null function so we had to a capture we
had to capture all of this intent inside
of that expression visitor so that way
we could write really natural c-sharp
that was also really performant in
sequel and it emitted nice and moment of
pride right it admitted a nice-looking
sequel it granted our use cases a little
narrower than pretty much you know any D
framework in general but what we ended
up with was really nice-looking
predictable sequel so our DBAs didn't
kill it actually at the time we were the
DBAs which is anyway so this became a
really predictable process to create
these maps so we went from stored
procedures and we immediately as soon as
we're this met system had any maturity
we immediately switched to doing this we
switched all of our definitions from
stored procedures to this
it was predictable and it saved
thousands of hours of development time
thousands of hours this is the back of
the napkin right from debugging all the
way to development because stored
procedures are really hard and nasty and
the really other cool thing that we were
able to do with our visitors is we were
able to button and additional
functionality on top of them such that
we could write and run additional
queries using that using that metadata
in order to make sure that we could
prevent duplicate data from moving from
one database to the other stuff like
that it became a huge boon to
productivity and people really liked
them and we and it went all the way down
to doing joins it was really awesome and
it saved a lot of time and it made a lot
of money too I think so what if we so
let's talk about some other real-world
examples so that's my personal story a
really good one well maybe you have you
know we were just we're wanting to do
something like order by like a string
right like order by some kind of
property if you've ever constructed an
API of some kind ever constructed API
lots of you have right we might have
done something like this at some point
or you might have at least seen or
consume something like this where you
had an API a customer's API and this is
a URL right where you had it on the
query string where you could order by
equals to name okay this is roughly this
is what it would look like inside if we
were doing a database query right but
the problem is is that it does not
expect a string it expects a lambda
right it expects an expression so this
thing doesn't exist so the solution for
us is to use the expression API to
actually cook a reference we're gonna
actually create that lambda in memory
using expressions so our goal is to end
up here we can do that by using this
iqueryable that I think I got from Stack
Overflow and tweaked a little bit so
what we're gonna do is use this we're
gonna create an extension method where
it's order by property or field and
we're gonna take an existing iqueryable
or ienumerable whatever the case may be
and take a field or property take a give
it a property or field name that we want
to order by and then do we want it to be
ascending or descending so there's a
very simple function signature so our
first thing is to edit if we want it
we're gonna make this an eye queryable
so that way
also be used by entity framework so we
can take advantage of the performance
you know the sending our order buys down
to the sequel server so we want to cook
at our expression and then we want to
apply it to our queryable chain and we
can do that by defining an expression
that represents the type so first thing
we need to do is capture the type so we
know type of t so we want to get the
type of that element right if it's an
eye queryable you could also just call
it you know dot element type same thing
so then we want to create the parameter
right we're trying to pay it we're
trying to recreate that seed to it goes
into seed name we're trying to recreate
that expression so first thing we need
to do is for our expression is build the
left side so we're building the
parameter pass in a type perfect we'll
give it the element type of our
iqueryable makes sense so far so then
what we want to do is capture the
property so we want to capture that
property that exists on that class so
what we'll do is call expression dot
property or field which is useful
because it's nice you don't have to know
one or the other
you can give it the the instance of the
thing that you want to capture in this
case is our expression parameter and
then we want to give it the property or
field name now at this point if the
property or field name didn't exist on
the on the class it would throw an
exception it wouldn't go anywhere from
here right but assuming that it did go
on we want to get our name right so then
we do this VAR this selector so we say
expression lambda and now we're ready to
construct it we're ready to construct
our expression so we pass in our
property our property expression which
is going to be the body of our
expression and then we're going to pass
in the parameter because we only have
one parameter so we only need one
parameter passed into the lambda so
we're gonna so we've achieved our goal
by using this order by but by just by
using expressions just cooking a custom
expression at runtime so here is if we
wanted to apply it use that actually use
that order by and actually apply it to
something hold on this is where we would
actually construct the call to order by
rights because we want we've got that
we've got the expression now we want to
apply it to the chain the iqueryable
chain and we do it by this so this looks
a little intimidating and this is the
part where discovery of the expression
API if you've got Visual Studio we got
link pad which is a great tool that
would help a lot I do a lot of my I
don't memorize
any of the expression API except the
simple stuff the rest of it I use
autocomplete I use intellisense to help
me with first thing we need though we
need the name of the order by method we
know that because we use it inside of
the numerable order by or order by
descending of course we could use name
of but for the sake of this example this
looks good too so if the thing is
ascending if we want to just order by
ascending then we just want the order by
method we want to order by method name
otherwise we want order by descending
and then we construct our expression
call so let's break this down a little
bit so first thing we need to do so
since the expression call since this
queryable order by order by descending
are static methods we don't need an
instance of something we actually just
need its type so we say type of
queryable because that's where our order
by an order by descending live we have
our name of the method and then we have
our generic type signature because
there's that it is a type it is order by
of blah blah it's the the type of the
IKE we reba land then the type of the
thing being selected and then we have
our parameters to that particular thing
since it's a static method it has two
parameters it has the previous
iqueryable and it has the selector the
lambda the expression that we created so
now we've gotten all this we've got
expression call and we've got it and
we've got it constructed let's take a
look at an example so I'm gonna use
Twitter tweet this bad boy out so I'm
gonna do hit escape get that out of
there order by property example we will
do that we will super cool and you can
follow along or just check my Twitter
later to try it yourself alright now
we're gonna go back to our fiddle and
what I've got here is just a set of
employees I've got a set of employees
I've got Gary I'm gonna make this just a
little bit bigger I've got Gary I've got
his hire date I've got Spencer I've got
Michael I've got Amy and for every
employee dot as query ball so we're
since it's just an in memory you know
set we call as queryable to get it
properly typed so we can use
our order by we're gonna say order by
property or field and we want to pass in
the name property because we want to
order by name and what we'll end up with
is I can pull this up a little bit or I
could just zoom out that's fine too
we'll end up with Amy Gary Michael
Spencer and here's the fully completed
thing I ripped shamelessly from this Oh
for my paging example which I think was
also that order by was taken from a
stack overflow question thank you stack
overflow and here's the implementation
the same thing we just described so now
you have the code you can look at it and
you can kind of mess with it and see
what it does and play with it a little
more if we put in higher date instead by
golly I should expect that we will order
this by higher date so we should get
Spencer on top and then Gary Michael Amy
Spencer Gary Michael Amy right because
ordering by higher date we don't put it
in the proper type or sorry the proper
name of a property we get an expression
so would it would throw one call to
property or field it would say QW er is
not a member of type employee so really
handy I have a little code to play with
too awesome
let's keep going let's do it I mean the
cool thing about once expressions is
once you know about them and what you
know once you know their power you can
start to really dream up and do a lot of
cool things what about our own rules
engine or search filter system or
whatever what's new let's do a rules
engine let's do a very simple rules
engine so we're gonna define something
called a rule and we're just gonna have
a and it's gonna have a name of a
property on an object and then a value
so we're gonna try to it we're gonna try
to create a representation of like a
predicate right where name equals
Spencer something like that and then
what we have is an operation and I've
just basically just kind of boiled it
down to greater than less than or equal
to nothing really complicated and then
what we have is basically we're making a
search system we're making a filter
system and we want to translate the
intent of that filter for one reason for
some reason or another it's really
complicated so expressions come to the
rescue right so we're gonna define our
rules and memories so we could say name
equal to Gary
and hired eight greater than 1 1 2016 so
we can cook an expression given a rule
set so this is where we could use our
binary / our binary expression again to
do some magic so we're gonna start with
an old binary expression and we're gonna
say for each thing rule in the thing
we're gonna create a new we're gonna
create a new expression so we're gonna
create we're gonna capture the property
so the property name from that rule and
then we're gonna capture the value in an
expression constant and then what we're
gonna call this method called make
binary and ruled out operation that
would not that would not necessarily
compile that would actually would not
compile we'd have to use the node type
that which is provided by the exposures
provided in an enum
but for sake of argument we'll just
shortening the code up just a little bit
let's pretend it's a node type we say
ruled out operation we'll say it's equal
and we were just basically wanting to
create an expression that represents
this property equals this value and then
if our binary expression is null let's
create a new binary expression or we'll
make a new we'll make it a Bryner exists
expression that includes the existing
expression so we'll just wrap them up
and wrap them up so we'll end up with
three binary expressions for three rules
right so this because of expression
magic and we're because we're using an
entity framework or whatever we're doing
this becomes this at the bottom so what
we've done is used a representation of a
rule in memory to actually translate it
and create a lambda really awesome and
of course I have an example for that too
because it's so awesome yeah everything
is great when you're clicking around
very good bye here we go here's our
rules engine so this is the thing right
here so we've done basically exactly
what we talked about which is we we've
just this is the implementation of the
rules engine almost the exact same way
that I did it except this one actually
compiles right so scrolling down we've
got our same list of employees and we've
got here a set of rules that we've
defined in memory so we've got name
equal to Gary hired a 26
greater than 2016 and so what we've done
is we've just taken the the rule we've
constructed we've just copy pasted the
example in a running dotnet fiddle got
our employee we've got our rule and then
this is the thing that actually takes
the rules in and then actually does
something with them so it's doing
exactly what I said it's cooking a
binary expression and that is cooking
more and more binary expressions until
it's represented captured all of the
intent of all of those rules in
expressions so when we run it which it
was already run we see that our rule is
Gary one one 2017 if we change this name
expression equal to something we'll end
up with nothing
so it doesn't write anything because
nobody's name is KSDK decay got here
let's see do we got oh we've got to
Gary's so what happens if we take out
this greater than this this higher date
rule and we just have Gary as we
predicted we run it and we get both of
our Gary's hooray
and that's expressions that's
expressions and a rules engine really
awesome stuff I have I have built
similar systems to this but there's all
of there's existing things out there
that you can use but sometimes when you
want to know what's going on under the
hood you need something custom that's
where that's where something like this
starts to shine so I'm an example like
this so let's talk about expression
versus reflection so expressions if you
cook a cut so how many people associate
reflection with slowness but that it's
slow it typically is compared to doing
something that's not it that's not
reflection right and reflection is
incredibly powerful I use reflection the
entire platform of rivet is built around
reflection because it's so powerful and
usually you just have to be fast enough
right but if you need to extract as much
performance as you can out of an
application you can often use expression
so you can take that reflection and if
you could take that reflection code if
you can convert it into convert it and
make it into an expression and then
compile it and then save that compiled
expression in memory what you've got is
something that is just as fast as code
that you wrote
that's compiled reflection does have
more power it just does
but expressions capture a lot of what
reflection can do so they're relay
they work hand in hand but there are
reasons to use one over another also got
to keep in mind that c-sharp does
compiler magic its compiler does magic
to make your life easier let's take this
for example so we've got two different
things we have a function and an
expression that represents that function
and we call combined strings we've got
to combine strings and basically we just
take in two strings and return those
strings concatenated right same code it
looks the same it behaves the same right
but so let's say okay well alright we
should be able to use the make binary
expression we should be able to say
expression type dot add right here right
and then give it the string parameter
one and string parameter to it nope
can't do that because exception the
binary operator add is not defined for
the type system string and system string
well what the heck's going on I just did
it I just did that one but under the
hood C sharps doing magic this one if
you looked at this expression inside of
link pad if you broke it down an
expression by a link pad a great way to
if you call the dump method on that
expression you could see all the little
component pieces link pad is awesome and
if you look at this thing under the hood
and a debugger or whatever or just break
it down and write it to the console this
doesn't use a bad it uses string ducking
cat it actually converts this into a
method call because under the hood
what's actually happening is string plus
one string one clustering to is actually
just using string concatenation doing
manage the magic sorry another thing is
that conversions have to be managed
explicitly if you pass an employee
object into a function that expects an
object just an object right it will just
work right c-sharp you don't have to
convert that you don't have to cast it
to an object it is an object c-sharp
knows this the compiler knows this but
under the hood is actually is casting it
to an object well if you do this in
expressions where you pass in an
employee where you're supposed to be
passing in an object what will happen is
the expression won't work it'll it will
throw an exception and say no these
expecting of type objects so then you
actually have to explicitly use
expression dot cast or something
actually cast it to type object so
conversions so conversions have to be
handled explicitly just a couple of
things as you're starting to use
expressions you start as you're starting
to experiment with them these are the
kinds of things that you'll encounter so
my favorite way to start is to
experiment I've got those dotnet fiddles
out there there on the TWiT there on the
tweeter as my boss says they're on the
Twitter they're on my website tonight's
net so you can go there and get those
code samples copy/paste them around mess
with them right that's what they
experimenting is probably your best way
to learn more about expressions just
using the API learning about its
capabilities what it's able to do is
gonna be your best tool link pad again I
love that tool link pad net one of the
versions is free it is worth every penny
of the 50 bucks that you pay to get
autocomplete and some other features if
you want to debugger and stuff like that
really useful tool and then Google the
expression API is covered well in Google
Stack Overflow it just is because lots
of people use them we all use them even
if we never knew it before now we know
it I'm gonna do what we do best which is
just use intellisense use intellisense
to your advantage it's there for a
reason and did I mention that you should
experiment if you want to mess with
expressions the best way to get started
with them my opinion anyways thank you
very much as usual I always say this
spiel at the end of my talks just
because I leave here today I'll fly back
to st. Louis tomorrow doesn't mean this
conversation has to end find me on
Twitter you have my email address and my
github all that stuff is on my website
Schneids dotnet I'm always happy to
answer questions and if you if you have
questions or if you have a specific
scenario or whatever you know reach out
to me I try to be responsive at least
you know so nothing more to say I hope
you've enjoyed this conference in DC of
course throws an amazing event I hope
you found it valuable and thanks for
coming thank you very much
[Applause]